hey guys Pete here this will be my
Westworld season 1 episode 7 recap and
review it will contain spoilers for
everything that's happened in the show
through episode 7 if you're not caught
up you'll want to stop watching now
let's get right into it we start out
with Bernard having a dream about his
son he's reading Alice's Adventures in
Wonderland to him while he's in the
hospital he has a moment where his son
says everything would be different
including me and Bernard assures him
that he's perfect
and that he will beat this moments later
his condition gets worse
but then Bernard wakes up in his bed at
the centre bernard is checking up on
hector he brings up a recent blacklisted
exchange with the guest hector says he
wanted to cut off a piece of him the
guest to take on his carry-on and put it
on the hood of his car hector answers
that this didn't change his opinion
about his world and then bernard shows
him a self-awareness test he shows him
photographs a modern life and hector
says they don't look like anything to
him assistant comes in and we learned
that hector is needed for a special
request by management and that else he
hasn't returned from the theater where
we last saw her william and lawrence are
playing cards on the train and we see
the loris in there as well they make
small talk for the most part and we see
that dolores still hasn't warmed up to
lawrence after what happened he says
that they came to him wanting to join up
with the Confederate OHS William tells
him this was Logan's idea and Lawrence
points out that they made it further
than Logan so maybe they have more of a
taste for this thing than they thought
Dolores looks out the window to see
heads and skulls on pikes
she asked what's going on and lawrence
tells her that they are in ghost nation
territory the most savage tribe there is
he says the heads are the folks who came
calling without an invitation they lock
down the train saying it's the only way
through but when they clear their
territory they'll be able to get off
Bernard is trying to reach Elsie but the
system says she can't be located goes to
see Teresa who called for him we noticed
that he no longer trusts her and that by
the time he leaves that the feeling goes
both ways other than that we find out
that management is looking over all
departments she says his is behind
schedule on their Diagnostics to which
she says that
be a problem she mentions if they spent
as much energy on their jobs as they do
on her investigation and he cuts her off
and assures her that that parts of the
things is over Teresa heads down a
hallway where we hear some sex going on
when she knocks on the door we find out
that management special requests for
Hector came from Charlotte who's in the
middle of using him for her pleasure
Teresa surprised but Charlotte has her
in for a meeting anyways she shuts up
Hector off and begins to explain
situation she tells Teresa that she's
always been good at her job and that's
why she was so shocked about the
woodcutters situation we learned the
whole game plan of what corporate is up
to Charlotte explains that the value of
the intellectual property at Westworld
is all that Delos cares about because of
a mistake one of her predecessors made
35 years of it only exists in one place
for that reason Ford has tremendous
leverage so they need to get the
information out of the park then they
can ask him to politely to retire if he
refuses they can show them that you know
they don't really need him and they can
move on she says she's going to give
Teresa one more chance to fix things
after putting her in her place
then she says that the gods require a
blood sacrifice they need to demonstrate
just how dangerous Ford's creations can
be she says they need somebody
thoroughly unexpected and the scene ends
with that we see may wake up in her bed
and then cut to the mariposa we see that
she's in her normal loop but that she
has a much different look on her face
when she comes in she looks around and
walks over to the piano closes the top
so it stops playing Clementine comes to
her and they carry on their normal
conversation but this time they don't
get interrupted so we learned more about
clementines backstory she has a family
with the farm with bad soil so she sends
them money
she thinks after a few more years of
working in the mariposa she'll be able
to get her family out of the desert to
take them somewhere cold and she can
have whatever life she wants whenever
she gets there then all the hosts but
maid freeze and we see the tax
approaching one says to the other that
it's the one at the bar they need and
Maeve's a knife in case they're coming
for her it turns out it's Clementine
they're after and we hear them say
whatever she
must have been pretty bad if they're
sending for them you know sending them
for her in broad daylight
mave looks disturb after they leave but
we don't see anything else we get a
really intense scene with Dolores and
William you talk about what they're
hoping to find she said that she didn't
know what she would find but she wasn't
gonna go back to the life she had where
she was had been so sure everything was
the way it was supposed to be basically
she wanted to live a life in the moment
rather than looking back or forward all
the time he tells her that when he was
young all he had books and he lived in
them then he came there and it was like
he could be part of the story she says
she doesn't want to be a part of a story
and then he tells her about his life at
home and how they'll be you know he'll
be married when he gets back this upsets
her and he tries to justify it by saying
he has a good life that's worth
pretending for and then she runs off of
course he ends up following her and when
he finds her in a different car he tells
her you know that how could he go back
to pretending after finding this they
kiss and get lost in the moment as
they're about to have sex for the first
time the scene cuts away back at the
center we see what Charlotte had planned
they pull in Ford and Bernard to
demonstrate what Teresa and her team
found in their investigation they have
Clementine men in a room with attack who
she approaches as she normally does he
punches her in the face and starts
beating her down Stubbs freezes things
and we see that the tech was a host who
was programmed to do what happened they
wiped clementines memory and have her
start again she's beat up and it's
pretty - it's a pretty tough scene to
watch all together when she approaches
this time he hits her but she
immediately starts fighting back she
ends up killing the other host by
smashing his head against the window
repeatedly they send Stubbs in but she
doesn't respond to the voice commands to
stop all motor functions when she starts
to advance on him he shoots and kills
her three six planes at the reveries
code had caused problem even when they
rolled back the update the hosts were
holding on to memories that make them
override their program of course at the
time it isn't clear if they set this up
but it sure feels like it
Ford doesn't say anything the entire
time Charlotte says they will have to
rebuild all the hosts from scratch and
when Bernard says you want us to do what
she fires him she gives him a chance to
explain why it isn't his fault but he
doesn't say anything at all Ford also
stays silent but gives a next-level evil
genius look at things as Bernard walks
away william sleeping on the train and
we see that dolores is drawing a pretty
amazing landscape of the canyon on a
drop cloth that's covering something
that's being shipped on this route
william wakes up and she says i know
last night was unexpected and if you
regret it but he swoops right in to give
her kiss she says she knows he has
someone waiting at home and then he
explains that you know he has this place
figured out now he used to think the
place was about pandering to your baser
instincts your deepest self it shows you
who you really are
he points out what he did to Logan was
what he always wanted to do to show him
what he actually thought about him and
says he never felt like he did last
night with any other woman he says she's
unlocked something in him and she says
that she's not a key she's just herself
he notices her drawing and asked what it
is she says she doesn't know she used to
paint it home but she only ever copied
the world around her she woke up this
morning and decided to draw something
new she imagined something beautiful a
place where the mountains met the sea as
they're talking the train comes to an
abrupt stop it's an ambush by the
Confederate OHS who blocked the tracks
so that they could ride up and light the
passenger car up with the Gatling guns
as they're firing we don't see what
everyone else is doing inside but after
they stop we see a horse ride out with a
white flag which I assume was Lawrence
it turns out to be Slim's body which
Lawrence shoots to set off the explosion
they use this as a diversion so they can
take off on horses to try to get away
but the Confederate oohs are obviously
chasing right behind the Lawrence gets
knocked off her horse so William has to
go back to rescue her right as the
Confederate o's are closing in the ghost
nation starts to attack them as they're
slaughtering them Lawrence Dolores
William and two more nitro fill corpses
make their escape
they ride until they get to a plateau
and then they see that area that Dolores
had drawn in her picture earlier she has
William stop and they both recognize
that it is what she had drawn Lauren
says they need to get going because the
ghost nation will come after them soon
and the two corpses are itching to get
involved in the war effort the Lord says
she's had enough of war and William
tells Lawrence this is where they part
ways he asked him what's beyond the
river to which Lawrence says you'd have
to ask the dust no one has ever made it
back from there maybe soon for repairs
and we noticed that Felix is working
with a different partner on her he sends
her away as he's finishing up and then
Maeve grabs his arm she wants to know
where Clem is and she forces Felix to
take her there we see that she's being
decommissioned as Teresa looks on as the
process is underway Bernhard comes in to
ask for a word with Teresa and they
leave Mavis upset watching what's
happening with Clementine but her and
Felix take off at that same time to not
draw any attention to himself she does
give Teresa look on her way past though
Bernard tells Risa that the test was a
sham he tells her that the show that
they put on had obvious signs of human
intervention in the code and that if he
noticed he couldn't imagine what Ford
thought about the whole thing but
nothing left to do he plays his card
that he knows that she was responsible
for the stray and the satellite
communication he then tells her there's
something wrong possibly related to the
code Arnold wrote where the hosts access
past memories that lead to improvisation
she tells him that her main concern has
always been the people in the park and
their safety which he acknowledges and
then says he has to show her something
they get on the elevator after he
mentions that some of the hosts were on
the verge of a change Sylvester is
trying to explain to Maeve why he had to
retire Clementine Maeve listens and then
basically lays out how things are gonna
be she tells them that she used to think
they were gods but then she realized
they were just men and she knows men she
tells them that she's going to get out
of there and despite their protestations
tells them that they're going to help
and the elevator Bernard and Teresa talk
over the events that led up to the
current situation it basically boils
down to her doing what she had to do in
the interest of Della's so that they
could get rid of Ford without him you
know being able to destroy all the
intellectual property Bernhard points
out that he wouldn't have let him
destroy all there were
and then she asked if he really thinks
that what corporate is really worried
about is the guest playing cowboy
predictably they arrive in the sector
where we saw Ford and his unregistered
host family as they go inside she
mentions that this building isn't on any
survey they have a par and Bernard
explains that's because they use hosts
to do most of their surveys their
program not to survey this place and
wouldn't be able to even if they saw it
they don't find the unregistered host
and Bernard says that Ford must have
moved them Theresa notices a door and
goes through it
Bernard makes a strange pause before
entering which gives us a hint at what's
to come they find what Bernard calls a
remote diagnostics facility that Ford
and his partner used to use when the
park was in beta he says he had no idea
this one was here and that the cottage
must have been built on top of it
there's equipment in there to build host
which Bernard says is slower than what
they have at the Mesa but it's still
newer than what they should have had
back then Theresa then says the obvious
that Ford's been making hosts out there
without telling anyone she notices
drawings on the desk where you know we
see the boy we see Dolores and then she
pauses when she sees the third she asked
Bernard if he's seen them and when she
shows him the drawing of himself he says
this doesn't look like anything to me at
the same time Ford arrives and tells her
that he's made them so that they don't
notice things that would hurt them
Bernard looks as shocked as us and
starts to melt down a little bit
Theresa calls for two monster and when
Bernard continues to freak out Ford's
simply just switches them all scene is
fantastically acted and Ford and theresa
go back and forth a bit which leads to
her trying to threaten him he tells her
that the board will do nothing and that
they try from time to time but he
basically always gets his way he repeats
again what he said about him and Arnold
building everything in the park from the
first showdown they had he says that the
hosts are the free ones here under his
control
she says Bernard isn't under his control
after all he brought her there and he
says Bernard did that because he told
him to at this point she realizes she's
in real danger and finds out she can't
use her phone where they
he reminds her once again that he built
everything in this place she mentions
that his time of playing God is over and
he turns that right right back around on
her he says he just wanted to tell us
stories and then it was Della's who
wanted to play God then he has Bernard
killer which he does without question he
calmly takes off his glasses and tie and
then walks over to her and beats her to
death with his bare hands
after the deed is done for tells him
that he ought to be getting back he has
a lot of work to do to get the new story
lines ready but Teresa's body slumped
against the wall the two leave and the
episode ends holy hell
so I guess we should just go ahead and
talk about the big reveal first I'm not
shocked that Bernard was a host there
was a lot of theories that pointed in
this direction and a lot of clues along
the way and with each episode it seemed
to be more and more possible what I will
say about the reveal though is that they
managed to keep the illusion going right
up and to the point where Bernard didn't
know about the door I'm not a hundred
percent sure without going back and
checking but if I remember that Sima
bernard showed up at the first time with
the cottage we couldn't see the door
then either it seemed like in that scene
that Ford just popped up out of thin air
when he stopped his father from
attacking him but yeah Bernards a host
as much as this was a reveal it also
opened a door to a million more
questions well get to all those in a
minute but let's talk about what else
happened first it's interesting to see
how the corporate thing is playing out
but it's kind of a mystery to me at
least that like what is their endgame
and what is this thing they keep talking
about that so much more valuable than
the actual park itself
they set Clementine up to take one for
the team and I must say that the
presentation of this scene while
completely hard to watch at first was
pretty amazing overall it was sad to see
Clementine go which was a nod to the
character building the show does with
the host even though we know they're not
real people and also the acting that
went into the character the way forward
sat back though and let them do the
whole thing like the whole played-out
thing without saying a word was
top-shelf bernard getting fired was a
bit of a shock at first but for silence
let on that this wouldn't actually
play out that way in retrospect had set
up the ending perfectly and even before
that set the story straight about who is
actually in charge it leaves me
wondering what else we don't know
especially considering that the reveries
from the beginning of the season have
turned out to play this huge role was it
all part of his plan from the beginning
and if so is he where is he headed with
this I definitely don't know which is a
good thing as far as I'm concerned I
don't think anyone thought that William
would stick to his I have a woman
waiting for me back at home story and
even though it was telegraphed I didn't
mind that he ended up falling for
Dolores I think it's clever that part of
what's attractive to him is that he
someone knows she's off script there's
something wrong with the way she's
acting and it's pretty good that we know
in the back of his mind that he still
likely has skepticism about the whole
situation in general charlotte turned
out to be a formidable player in the
game but we learned quickly that she's
no match for four on the other side of
things we found out Maeve's plan is to
leave the park which that should get
interesting I mentioned this in my last
video and after the fact concluded that
it was likely the only thing that she
would actually want again tani Newton's
acting was incredible and I kind of
loved Felix and Sylvester in that their
whole purpose is to have no defenses
against her so now that one theory came
to be that Bernard was a host I can
think of a couple that come to mind
during the reveal first might be the
most obvious but it's worth mentioning
in case anyone missed it he had Bernard
kill Teresa in an area of the park that
is off the radar and where he can make
his own host now I saw the trailer and
it looks like he's pulling a sheet over
Teresa's face with Stubbs and Charlotte
right there so I'm not saying that he's
trying to replace her per se but I
couldn't help thinking while I was
watching is what is stopping him from
killing anyone and then just replacing
that person with the host that's under
his control
I mean Bernard is basically a boss in
the organization so if he's a host it
means that Ford's pretty good at
concealing the identities of hosts if he
wants to even if he didn't kill Teresa
with the intention of replacing her I
think it stands the reason that he could
also it's a stretch but they're two
people president when he's pulling the
sheet over her could be hosts as well
the rabbit hole gets pretty deep there
so I'm just gonna leave it at that
but what but that's what I was thinking
when they left her body against the wall
I mean the shot at Bernard beating her
was set up so that we watched it happen
behind the new host being built since
Bernard is a host what do we think as
far as his origin he could just be a
random host like Dolores seems to be or
he could be a man whose image Ford
recreated a host with or there's that
popular theory out there that he could
actually be a host that's built in
Arnold's image I'm not ready to say that
he is the recreation of Arnold but there
is a compelling argument for one of the
clues hinges on there also being
alternate timelines so the fact that we
saw that room under the cottage and it
looked a lot like where Bernard was
interviewing Dolores by himself kind of
fits in with that also the whole idea
that he couldn't see his own drawing
kind of makes you wonder about whenever
he looked at that picture and he saw you
know what looked like a blank space that
it might have been him that was there
anyways that the fall along with the the
timeline thing if you're not 100% sure
how it works there are two timelines and
it's confusing because both include
Dolores thirty years ago Dolores is
running around with William and present
time Dolores is the one that had the
conversation with her father Peter
Abernathy and then passed on these you
know that these violent delights have
violent ends to Mays she's also the one
that interacts with Teddy after he's
updated with his backstory and the one
we see dragged into the barn by the man
in black it's confusing I know but
that's the part that really makes it
hard to say since we see Dolores and we
expect that her story is linear as in
all the things that happen are happening
one right after the other anyways when
Bernard is talking to her in a little
room like that which we don't see anyone
else ever use plus she's always clothed
which is strange compared to all the
other interviews we see the techs having
you know because they're always naked
all of this could be explained away of
course but seeing that room might be a
clue that those scenes where he talks to
Dolores alone aren't what we believe
them to be I've been skeptical about the
multiple timelines but after seeing the
new logo and
last episode kind of exactly in the same
place where the old one was when in that
welcome video when william first arrived
well that's getting harder and harder to
explain away I'm not exactly sure how
things will play out but can say for
sure that the show is great about
putting enough misdirection in there to
keep us guessing not confirmation on
anything besides the fact that Bernard
is a host but a lot of stuff to think
about until the next episode airs as
dolores i'm william converge on the maze
and the man in black gets close to
himself i guess it'll all start making
more sense i mean it seems like a
blaring hole in the whole thing if that
William is headed to the maze if he's
the man in black why doesn't the men in
black already know but if you think
about it Dolores has never really told
him that's what she's looking for and oh
yeah where the hell is Elsie let me know
what you guys think please like the
video if you enjoyed it and leave me
comments to discuss all the different
things that happen I'll try to respond
to any question if you have and please
subscribe to my channel so you'll know
when my new videos come out thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon